I
SAID VERSU
DO TT NAUTA WHO
ECAL> T THAT ST
HALLLE
COLLINS KEUMP IF
NOT REALLY.
THIS INDTMO SIONS IN02
PRESIDENT SHD
DOCUS HIDICTMENT
SPECIFICALLY L
HEUDORDINGDAY WEELY BROUGHLE
I.
TO SHOW A DOCUMENT TO MEMBERS OE
QUQUING A OK
.
Y REPORTINND INCF 20Y INSTER
REPRESENTIPO
TI WO
ANHA WIM ANSHOULD
T GET TOO OSE.
STE FIRST UPES
WE HAVCES OFHE RE
T E
THERE AR31IS ONE OFTENPEYOTAN C.
ON
E FACTT THE FORMER
THEYAYD HIS -- TOLD HIS   OF THO
LAWYER TBI
AND THE GRAND JURYT  DIDSE DOCU-
LIE.SNNEWEN IS DID T TSTIFY,E LS
RESULT OF A COURT OR
>> DOES THISHAT
PR
LIE?LAY THIS OUT BUT
LISTS THSTN ITS ATRMER PRESIDEC.
ALSE FORMERENDIRECTED THE WALT
HIS
ACCORDING TO THEEDERAL OASO ARO.
PROSEC IS ATT UT S.
THESE BOXEL THEM
FROM CD OF TIMNDRCH.>>ANE NOAB
TO REPORT THATE ATM., HEHO
OR SO,S
GOING TO BE MAKING.
T VERY UN N THIS,
WBE
FOR HERE?
WHAT DO YOK,VA
THIS IS GOINTO?
TH TUMULARNCE OF - KN JUSTICE TA
AN GREAT F SPEAK
ANYTHING OR SAY ANHI OUTSI COUR.
AN OF JACK SMITHODAYTH YOU
EXPLAIN TO THEWHONE,HIN HA
DONENTRAF IO AL
GOARCH 30t  CHh OF 22.IGATION HA
AND YOU KNOW,  IMPORTANT FCK SM
STAND BEFOREERAS THEEONE T
C AND EXPLAIN WHAT
ITHIS
, WHY  IMPORTANT T
WS  THESE
'S 1 TO TENTION OF NATIONA
INFORMN,N TO  ADDITIONAL TS
BY THE, EACH OF TH OCORD, CORRU
LISTING LDMPBYHIMSELF OR ANAUTA
FALSEMEREPRESENTATIONS.
>> EACDOCUMENT IS A --
>> AND WE KNOW WHICH DOCUMENT
T. HAVEN'T KNOWN. 38 IS THE CY
.
>> I JUST HAA JA
HA BEEN RI
YEAW ON.
WALT
IM H
MA-A-LAGO CLUB. F
SOMEOSXEWEHE
S WHIT
SOASMENTS IN A BALOO
WE TK PIONAGTHE PERSON'STITY.EAO
NOD WH IS TANT
ESPIONE,THK ABOUE
ARN OF PP T US
DO NOT HAVTH
RESPONSIBILITY OOSIT INCDE OTHEY
HAVE TTS HEM IN P ATOIT  VIEWEOE
CLEARLY IDEN. LET'S JUST IS W BN
IGENCE
AGENCIES, I HARI
OR A
YEARS.
COTR DOCUMENT NCERNIILBYFOREIGNL
L STANDING F
FOREIGN MEANING THESE
TO BE SHARED THYBODY OUTSIDE T
INENCE COMMUNITY DUE TO EIR SEEO
YINTEENFOREIGN AT
TIY FOREIGN CO
MARI.
S INDICTMENT IG. THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THE DEPOSITION OF
NAUTA WHERE H